[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Jody Is
With Us in Springfield Illinois hi Jody
welcome to the Ramsey Show hi there hey
what's up I well I'm kind of embarrassed
to ask this
question but I am a
50-year-old Widow who has been widowed
for 15
years um I have helped put my children
through col college and I have no
retirement so I am ready to start
retirement and I don't even know where
to begin and how much to put in there's
nothing embarrassing about any of that
it sounds sounds like make me feel good
sounds like you're a wonderful person we
just need to get on the ball right yes
yeah so what do you
make I make about I was just sitting
here figuring this out um I bring home
about
36,000 taome a year MH okay so your
income somewhere around in the low 40s
uh maybe 45 yeah all right what do you
do I am a social worker okay all right
and do you have any
debt I do not your house is paid for yes
well that's great
news that means most of your income can
go toward
investing so you have zero saved right
now right what do you have in the
bank well here's what I have I have my
emergency fund of
$1,000 I have my three months I have
three months of my Emer or for my you
know in case something
happens um but that's about all I have
at this point so I'm I'm on the Dave
Ramsey boat I just I'm scared I it's to
a point to where sometimes I cry because
I'm like what am I going to do
M you know because I don't know because
when my husband passed away you know I
used like life insurance and all that
kind of stuff to pay my house off so
yeah you know we had a roof over our
head and all that kind of stuff because
my kids were seven and 10 when all of
this happened wow well you've had a lot
of Life happen hard I totally understand
a l we're not here to beat you up we
want to give you some good next steps to
take and if you're following the steps
now that puts you at baby step four
because you have no debt fully funded
emergency fund and really at step seven
because you have a paid for house and so
now the kids are they schools paid for
we got to put our own mask now uh put
our own mask on and that looks like
investing for retirement as aggressively
as possible do you have a retirement
plan through your
employer here's what I have and I I
didn't know what route to go but there's
a
403b okay I don't know much about that
I've kind of look you know do they have
a
match no okay I would not do that then I
would first do okay I mean I may do some
there but we would first do a Roth
IRA okay just a plain Roth not a
traditional a Roth a Roth so what I want
you to do is go to Ramsey solutions.com
and click on smartvestor and get a
smartvestor pro in your area to sit down
with you and they can help you run some
calculations okay now let me give you an
example you bring home $33,000 a month
you do not have any bills except
survival bills you have no debt no rent
no nothing okay correct if you were to
save
invest
$1,000 a month for 15 years at 65 you're
going to have right around a half a
million dollar right around
$500,000 really yeah okay what this
means is not that you're rich and it's
really not enough but it's enough to
make sure you're not cold and
hungry right because it will produce
then let's just let's just reverse
engineer this which is very interesting
okay let's pretend It produced 10% a
year on the mutual funds after that and
that you retired and had no retirement
income and I suspect you probably have a
retirement with your government agency
don't you that they furnish you
a
pension uh yeah actually uh my husband I
get a pension off of him but that thing
but do you get a pension from your work
when you retire no huh okay it's just
Social Security I pay in yeah yeah
absolutely which is nothing which is
horrible but that's okay all right so if
you had a half a million at 65 or 67 or
whatever and it was invested at
10% 10% of 500 ,000 is 50,000 a year
right without touching the nest egg
without touching the goose it will lay
50,000 golden eggs a
year wow and so you'd actually be making
more retirement than you are
now so no kitty so you're going to be
okay that's the point you're not going
to be rich but even if I'm if my numbers
are off a little bit and they might be
one way or another actually they
probably are off in this case because
you probably will not be making 36 ,000
for the rest of your life you'll
probably be making more and so you could
invest probably more later
agreed right yeah so the I did that
based on $1,000 in your current income
so so I want you to sit down with a
smart Vester Pro and we don't know how
the scenarios will compare to actual
life but you can run some scenarios like
I just did just to get the idea that I
don't have to
cry cuz if you'll start now Jody and
you'll start investing close to $1,000
or more than $1,000 a month you get your
budget tight and you do that you're
going to be
okay matter of fact you're gonna be
better than
okay that makes me that makes me cry
just being happy yeah so I want you to
sit down but it also needs to make you
get on the budget and do it it also mean
me you to get on the phone and get on
with those smart Vestor pros and go sit
down with them and learn and let's get
this stuff started not next week not
next year now now okay right now it and
because every day you put this off it
gets harder if you put it off a year
it's going to take
1,200 yeah don't put it off anymore you
put it off as long as you can the fuse
is burning so I want you scared enough
that I scare you into action but I don't
want you terrified anymore so you're
paralyzed I got it I'm on it I'm doing
it today I love you you're awesome call
us back and let us know how it's going
okay okay thank you guys so much I
appreciate it thank you sweet lady love
that she just needed a little motivation
that she's not doing as as bad as she
thought she was and the time to start is
today what's interesting about what we
do for a living when we talk about
getting out of debt or we talk about
Building Wealth numbers actually give
you a result that gives you hope when
you run math okay you know got $100,000
in debt I'm never going to get out
what's
33,000 a year for three years I mean
it's 2,600 bucks a month and you make 15
,000 shut your winding up you know all
of a sudden the numbers give you Ma give
you hope right the math gives you hope
in her case it's $1,000 a month and for
for the next 15 years and not missing a
month and getting started immediately
and getting good returns and good mutual
funds which probably that 403b does not
have that's why I directed her away from
that you know let's go first to the Roth
IRA with more control more options lot
better options a lot better mutual fund
options out there now I can be off and
if y'all want to argue with my numbers
that's fine argue with my numbers but
here's the point get with it you know
and and you know I might be if I'm half
wrong she's still going to have 25
$26,000 a month coming in uh or 25
$26,000 a year coming in uh versus
nothing which your little plan you
critique critic people out there creates
nothing that's what critics create
nothing well the new one Dave is well a
million dollars isn't enough anymore
Dave that means a half million dollars
is half of not enough
but it's more than you got if you be
broke and crying about it hello yeah
we'd love for you to have multiple
Millions but I mean in this case you
could see 500,000 would still change
your life the way she's the only way
she's going to get to over a million is
she's going to raise her income
substantially so she could invest twice
as much CU 2,000 a month yeah for 15
years at 12% my mutual funds have
averaged 12% for the last 30 years my
personal portfolio and I'm not a genius
the market is average 11.8% in the S&P
so bu God shut up and go do it you know
so could you could you end up with a
million dollar in 15 years yes two grand
a month that's it roughly I mean there
it is ding ding this is the Ramsey Show